[Musica]
Vi chiedo la massima collaborazione
dovreste fare un attimo solo Silenzio
assoluto
perché io devo farvi sentire una cosa
direste mai giuro non è uno spogliarello
direste mai che un rumore così
impercettibile come quello di una
cerniera lampo è in grado di far
scappare a gambe levate o meglio a zampe
elevate l'animale più temuto forse al
mondo dall'uomo il lupo
eppure è così questo rumore che appunto
è stato amplificato col microfono
altrimenti non l'avreste probabilmente
sentito e rumore che io dovevo evitare
di fare
durante i miei anni di studio in
Appennino dedicati appunto ai lupi me ne
sono occupata per quasi 20 anni e c'era
una tecnica che utilizzavamo in estate
che si chiama wolfhowling e che consiste
nell'emettere degli ululati registrati
ai quali lupi rispondono sono ululati
veri ma registrati viene usato un
amplificatore E perché facevamo questo
perché i lupi così sollecitati tendono a
ululare a loro volta sono animali molto
territoriali Quindi se sentono un
ululato che non conoscono si incavolano
si arrabbiano
Ma la cosa bella è che in estate i lupi
hanno i cuccioli e anche i cuccioli
ululano iniziano quando hanno circa
15-20 giorni ed emettono degli ululati
molto acuti Perciò in questi anni
Dedicati ai lupi ho dovuto imparare non
solo a fare un silenzio estremo per non
spaventarli mentre usavamo questa
tecnica ma anche ad ascoltare molto bene
per riuscire a distinguere lupi adulti
da lupi un po' più giovani e fino a
poter appunto riconoscere i lupi
piccolissimi Questo è un dato per la
scienza molto importante perché se una
specie si riproduce vuol dire che in un
buono stato di conservazione
Ma la cosa interessante Qual è appunto
che questo allenamento all'ascolto che
avveniva Poi di notte mi ha proprio
insegnato che le altre forme viventi si
manifestano non soltanto alla vista ma
anche all'udito quindi
diventa fondamentale per occuparsi di
animali di animali selvatici di
biodiversità anche aprire bene le
orecchie sono sicuro che anche voi in
realtà soprattutto se avete la fortuna
di vivere in campagna avete ben presente
molti suoni emessi dagli animali
pensiamo ai grilli la sera alle cicale
che ci stordiscono adesso durante il
giorno e gli uccelli che iniziano a
cantare all'alba i gabbiani Ieri ne sono
passati tanti qua sopra
se andate a fare una passeggiata sul
promontorio del Gargano si sentono i
Caprioli si dice in gergo abbaiare il
loro richiamo di allarme gli animali
mettono tantissimi suoni è come se là
fuori ci fosse un concerto Selva ggio
che va avanti 365 giorni l'anno 24 ore
su 24 in questo concerto Si alternano
seconda dell'ora del giorno e della
stagione
moltissime specie ma c'è un problema c'è
una nota dolente
che gli animali non sono gli unici ad
emettere suoni anche noi parliamo
tantissimo
ma non solo comunichiamo utilizzando
appunto la voce e mettiamo anche un
sacco di rumore moltissimo rumore così
tanto
che è stata creata una categoria di
inquinamento apposta che si chiama
inquinamento acustico o inquinamento
sonoro ed è una forma di inquinamento di
cui si parla veramente molto poco
pensate ai nostri mezzi di trasporto
dagli aerei ai motorini pensate a tutti
gli strumenti che utilizziamo Per
compiere lavori dai tosaerba alle
motoseghe piuttosto che i trapani
pensate anche al rumore che fanno i
nostri eventi con la musica magari a
volume altissimi Insomma tutto rumore
che produciamo per decine di Decibel non
solo a un impatto negativo sulla nostra
salute sia fisica che mentale questo
ormai è comunque provato dalla medicina
ma ha un impatto devastante anche sugli
animali selvatici Oltre che su quelli
ovviamente domestici come Forse qualcuno
di voi sa
un impatto subdolo posso farvi alcuni
esempi c'è uno studio che ha messo ad
esempio in evidenza come i fringuelli
perdano capacità cognitive all'aumentare
del disturbo l'aumentare del rumore si
distraggono si spaventano e non sono in
grado di compiere delle azioni di avere
dei comportamenti che avrebbero
altrimenti normalmente
l'usignolo è un uccello canoro molto
famoso ha un canto molto melodioso che
spesso le persone addirittura
riconoscono anche se non sono esperte
Ebbene gli usignoli hanno modificato ad
esempio il loro canto perché non
riescono più a comunicare con i
potenziali partner o le potenziali
partner perciò mentre prima non so
potevano cantare con questo tono con
questa intensità e dire Ehi ciao Come
sei bella ad una potenziale partner
adesso devono fare Ehi ciao Come sei
bella perché altrimenti lei non sente
non sto scherzando è una cosa molto
seria ci sono degli Studi addirittura
sulle rane sugli anfibi che hanno messo
in evidenza come il loro canto che ha
sempre uno scopo riproduttivo
Mentre una volta era udibile ad esempio
ha quasi un chilometro di distanza
adesso da quella stessa specie è udibile
a meno di 100 metri di distanza a causa
del rumore del traffico
ci sono altre popolazioni di anfibi che
si stanno letteralmente estinguendo
a causa del rumore perché il rumore
stressa questi animali al punto che le
loro difese immunitarie si abbassano
Quindi sono più soggetti a malattie
fanno più fatica a riprodursi e di
conseguenza alle popolazioni piano piano
scompaiono perché il tasso di mortalità
supera quello di natalità ci sono
popolazioni di uccelli che hanno
abbandonato intere aree geografiche
Perché non riuscivano a vivere non
riuscivano a procurarsi il cibo in
quelle zone a causa del rumore da noi
prodotto
Pensate ai cetacei pensate i cetacei
sono le balene del film animali che
sicuramente Avete presente o i
chirotteri i pipistrelli questi animali
utilizzano una tecnologia molto
sofisticata al biosonar lo utilizzano
per orientarsi nello spazio lo
utilizzano per procurarsi il cibo lo
utilizzano per comunicare con i propri
simili Ebbene anche lì sotto il pelo
dell'acqua i sonar dei nostri delle
nostre imbarcazioni il rumore prodotto
dai sviluppatori le trivellazioni sui
fondali marini e anche addirittura gli
eventi che avvengono fuori dall'acqua Ma
che sono percepibili con il loro rumore
anche sott'acqua bene Stanno
Praticamente interferendo con quello che
è il paesaggio sonoro di queste specie
impedendo loro di comunicare
correttamente procacciarsi il cibo
trovare un rifugio orientarsi nello
spazio
Ho assistito personalmente a branchi di
lupi che ululano quando passano le
ambulanze a sirene spiegate o suonano le
campane Questo vuol dire che questi
animali ormai si sono così assuefatti al
rumore che noi produciamo che non hanno
più ben chiaro il confine tra un ululato
vero di un lupo e un suono che vagamente
lo ricorda Nel dubbio ululano che è
abbastanza pazzesco e perfino le
relazioni tra prede e predatori si sono
alterate perché sapete bene che un
predatore spesso tende un agguato alle
sue prede e entrambi si percepiscono a
volte non solo attraverso l'odore ma
attraverso dei rumori lievissimi che
magari questi animali
provocano all'interno della vegetazione
nella quale si muovono
la situazione è tragica perché la
biodiversità come sapete bene è
estremamente in crisi parliamo di sesta
estinzione di massa
sulle popolazioni animali non incide
negativamente soltanto
l'inquinamento da plastica o
l'inquinamento luminoso di cui si parla
un pochino di più ma anche i cambiamenti
climatici Quindi a questo si aggiunge
oggi l'inquinamento acustico si può fare
qualcosa
si può sicuramente fare qualcosa e qui
dovrebbe essere la politica che adotta
appunto delle politiche di sviluppo più
compatibili con un livello di rumore più
accettabile Non solo per le specie
animali probabilmente anche per noi
negli ambienti urbani anche per noi
esseri umani Ma noi per primi come
individui possiamo fare qualcosa e
possiamo cioè ricordare una vecchia
lezione che ci hanno insegnato quando
eravamo piccoli e cioè ascoltare fare
silenzio e ascoltare perché non siamo
gli unici ad avere una voce e il
silenzio fuori non è vuoto ma è ricco di
discorsi è ricco di
parole che forse non comprendiamo perché
non ne conosciamo il significato Eppure
sono di vitale importanza per le specie
animali che li utilizzano e quindi sono
venuto su questo palco a farmi un po'
portavoce di questo messaggio un po' da
traduttrice seria Impariamo ad ascoltare
Allora siamo reimparando a rispettare e
come sapete bene la natura ha proprio
bisogno di rispetto rispetto significa
garantire il diritto all'esistenza anche
no ascoltare significa garantire il
diritto ad esprimersi
E da qui il mio invito quindi è proprio
di partire dall'ascolto per arrivare a
rialzare il volume della biodiversità e
tutelarla grazie
[Applauso]